so last week there was another paper
which I found quite interesting so I
thought I'd tell you about it
the title of the paper is a planar
rhombic charge separated tetris sila
cyclobutadiene so what does that mean
well let's begin with benzene many of
you I hope know that benzene is a flat
molecule which has six carbons and each
carbon has a hydrogen attached to its
c6h6 and for a long time
chemists have wondered about the
molecule C 4 H 4 where you've got four
carbons and four hydrogen's rather than
the six carbons and hydrogen's in
benzene so you might think that c4 h4
might be a square C 4 H 4 turns out to
be very reactive and it took chemists
ages and ages to make it but when they
did make it a very low temperature they
discovered it wasn't a square but it was
a rectangle so it was pulled out in this
direction with one side much longer than
the other because chemists really like
the periodic table once they've done
something with carbon they asked what
would happen with the same silicon
compound now you can't make si for H 4
because it's far too reactive but you
can make a so-called analogue where the
hydrogen has been replaced by a really
complicated large group when you have
large groups it surrounds the reactive
part and stops it reacting at least
slows down its reactions so you can see
it so in this case they use this group
here which is called a mind where the e
stands for ethyl groups and the M stands
for methyl groups in the end and not
sure what for so you have this big lump
in which the silicon can join on to this
bond here so they made the compound so
the question is would it also be a
rectangle a much to everybody's surprise
it turned out to be a rhombus rhombus is
adamant to
and me you have four silicon atoms which
are all the same they're all bonded to
the same groups but two of them have a
big angle and two of them have a small
angle and this is really quite unusual
now it turns out is not completely
unexpected because when people made c4h
4 they realize from theoretical
calculations it could be a rectangle or
it could be a Damond
so they're done calculations that said
that this could occur but now with the
silicon compound it's the first time
it's been discovered observed in nature
so now the big question is if you make
the carbon or germanium analogues of the
same compound that's 4 carbons or for
germanium
each with this big group attack in mind
attached to it what would happen then
could you make diamond shaped carbon
compound and it's things like this that
make chemists really think about their
theories and their understanding of how
compounds form particular shapes so yet
again we have an interesting idea that
makes chemists think differently